a dramatic rescue effort for a capsized
boat off louisiana has now become a
desperate search for 12 crew members who
are still missing
it's all unfolding about seven miles
from the coast after hurricane force
winds
toppled the vessel called the c corps
power our lead national correspondent
david begno is following this in new
orleans
david six were rescued one body has been
found
but do we know what happened exactly
we don't know yet the coast guard hasn't
said look anthony there was a severe
thunderstorm watch but the weather
turned out to be
far worse than even the forecasters had
predicted some family members have said
they heard
that there are people still trapped on
the ship but the coast guard is not
saying that's true
as of now this is a very interesting
boat it's a lift boat
this is what it looks like when it's in
the water looks like normal ship going
through the water right
but there are three legs sticking out
into the air when those legs go
down into the water this photo shows how
the boat is lifted
out of the water it looks like an oil
rig and that's how it operates
i just spoke with the coast guard they
had one plane and
two boats in the search area last night
actively looking for these individuals
battling some pretty rough water coast
guard rescue teams are in a race against
time
because this is still a rescue mission
they say the latest video from the wreck
shows
the water crashing against the ship that
is capsized in the gulf of mexico
we're giving it all we got that's the
best i can tell you the c
corps power left port fouchon at 1 30 pm
local time on tuesday
around 3 p.m the national weather
service issued an alert
warning of steep waves and asked sailors
to get to safe harbor
then at 4 30 pm the coast guard received
a distress message
from a good samaritan that the boat was
in trouble
this is what that storm system looked
like hurricane forced wind gusts up to
90 miles per hour and off the coast
there were videos
from people on other boats in the same
area of the gulf
showing the treacherous conditions with
waves higher than 10 feet
[Music]
we did not anticipate the weather that
we saw
families of those missing gathered at a
firehouse on port fouchon
you gotta hang on to hope because he's
coming home so
among the missing is chas morales he's a
crane operator on the sea corps power
and he's a father of three
his mother dara says he had picked up an
extra shift to work that day
they asked him if he wanted to to make
extra money he knows he's got to provide
for the kids
they love that dad and he loves his
babies
so much we need him
to come home also missing 62-year-old
gregory walcott
he worked in the ship's kitchen his
niece crystal sadler
says he also had picked up extra shifts
to work and that's why he was on the
boat that day
what's affecting us the most is that
we're not hearing anything
it's just dreadful just sitting there
waiting for the phone to ring
so we trying to just stand in faith that
we're going to get the phone call soon
that he's found
safe and he's alive
12 people missing as we're coming up on
nearly 48 hours of searching
tony david but we're going to hold on to
the fact that it is still a rescue
mission at this point not a recovery
mission thank you very much it's a
powerful story those waves 10 feet
that's a pretty rough sea out there and
and those pictures don't look good but
the weight has got to be agonizing you
want the phone to ring and on the other
hand you
don't want the phone to ring it's news
that you don't want but as you said it's
still right now a recovery mission but
the
pictures are tough one search plan and
two boats in the water still looking for
people
all right we wish them luck